the world's oldest a travel company
Thomas Cook has collapsed after failing
to secure a last-minute bailout more
than half a million people worldwide er
currently on holiday with that group
Britain's Civil Aviation Authority is
beginning an operation to bring home
some 150,000 British customers stranded
abroad lcaa had Tim Johnson had this
message for Thomas Cook travelers if
customers passengers have a flight
booked out from the UK today
unfortunately your flight has been
cancelled so please don't go to the
please don't go to the the airport if
you're overseas on a Thomas Cook holiday
then you can continue to enjoy your
holiday the CIA is launching a
repatriation this is the largest
repatriation since the Second World War
okay the collapse of rescue talks
causing panic among travelers online
Gerhard Alford's from DW business here
now with more
good morning Gerhart Ron what a
situation hundreds of thousands of
people stranded how are they going to
get home who's going to pay for it
well it looks like the British
government is going to pay for it they
as we just heard they have launched a
sort of a rescue operation and one
tricky thing though is does it only
apply to British customers or or not and
you know what I've just been on the
phone with the Civil Aviation Authority
in Britain for 15 minutes at the poor
woman was not able to guarantee me that
if you don't have a British passport
that you can indeed go she says what's
valid is this first sentence if you are
currently abroad and we're flying we're
flying back to the UK with Thomas cook
we are providing new flights to your
turn to the UK that does not explicitly
exclude foreigners okay oh there's hope
and the CIA says go on the website there
are numbers for each of our each of the
destination contact the number and find
out in detail what's going to happen
with your flight ok tensions really
focusing in on this question a number of
others as well Thomas Cook the CEO of
its CEO rather Peter Funkhouser also has
made a statement let's take a listen to
that I would like to say sorry to all
our customers
those who are on holiday with us now and
those who have poked with us in the
coming months
it is deeply distressing to me that it
has not been possible to save one of the
most loved grants in travel ok deeply
distressing there now talks to throw
Thomas a cook a lifeline collapse at the
eleventh hour what pushed this 178 year
old company over the line well basically
they were in trouble there's a huge pile
of debt a hundreds of millions of debt
and they were in trouble for a while
there have been two get get rid of debt
they have been trying since before the
summer to sell the Thomas Cook Airlines
to sell condor their German subsidiary
because those airlines are profitable
they wanted to sell them to shore up
their their holiday travel business word
of that got out people are suddenly not
so sure anymore their demand hoteliers
for example than demanding upfront
payments which puts pushed them further
into debt so in the end it kind of was a
mixture than their main investor the
Chinese large Chinese company didn't
want to stomp up all the cash the
British government of course not very
keen to help a failing business and set
a precedent because with brexit there
might be other companies that might ask
for government assistance in the future
so it was basically a perfect storm and
in the end of that made it from that
affecting some half a million people
that perfect storm you mentioned China
there that's just one signal of all the
uncertainty out there for the travel
industry right now but what about brexit
you know is it playing a role you know
this being based in Britain everything
that's happening yeah
analysts have been saying for a while
that breaks it the uncertainty around
breaks it have stopped the largely
British customer base of Tom's cook
their travel arranges people were not
sure will we be in the EU by October by
by March and then buy it got moved to
October lots of uncertainty lots of
foreign travel plans are being canceled
I mean Thomas Cook has only had only
sold in the first half of the year 57%
of the packages that they wanted to sell
so I'm really really in trouble em 1.5
billion pound loss in the first half and
brexit does play a big role also now
that the government is not really keen
to help also to do with brexit so yes
absolutely there it does play well
Gerhard thanks for that clarification
for foreign nationals or non of British
citizens but I guarantee I'll feel first
looking into this story from our
business desk